hey jesse
you might have a whole lot of explaining
to do there might be no better childhood
memory than settling into the couch
after a long day of school and turning
on disney's jessie
getting to catch up and bond with jesse
emma luke ravi and zuri
never got old even if they were
fictional well
we hate to burst your happy jesse bubble
but we're here to tell you that your
favorite disney show was actually filled
with so many mistakes that the editors
never caught
we know we were also shocked to find out
just wait until you see some of them for
yourself
buckle up a giant lizard using a hawk as
a pinata
alright let's head straight in this
might not be a physical editing mistake
but it definitely got us scratching our
heads
we are told that ravi is the newest
addition to the ross family in the pilot
episode and according to luke he's been
with them for an
entire month in that episode we also see
the ross kids head out of their
penthouse to wait for the school bus
here's where it gets confusing ravi
waiting for the school bus meant he was
heading to class
right so how come in the episode are you
cooler than a fifth grader
ravi is preparing for his first day of
school because he's finally allowed
now ready to start school with emma and
luke what better day to edit
this continuity mistake definitely went
over the production team's heads
or maybe they didn't take it too
seriously because it was the pilot
episode
find one main friend meet all his
friends
and bam you're popular you'd think that
disney would be a little more careful
about mistakes when it came to huge
crossovers like this
jessie and austin and ally episode but
that isn't the case
in this episode jesse and emma help a
stranded austin and gang get to his
rooftop performance
oh austin when you know rich people
there's always
another way with a helicopter while they
get the iconic austin moon to his
performance they're seen
seconds later in the crowd cheering them
on um
how exactly did they land the helicopter
hop out and join the crowd in that
amount of time
we might as well have been watching
wizards of waverly place at that point
really because that's not what i'm
saying we all know the iconic opening
scene of jessie
the one where jesse arrives in new york
with a bucket of dreams and then
literally gets thrown out of a taxi cab
because she lost her wallet
in the taxi she has a coffee cup in her
hand that clearly still had something in
it because she was trying to drink from
it
well then how come when she gets kicked
out of the taxi her cup is thrown at her
head and no liquid comes out
did she just magically finish off her
coffee or did the editors hope we just
wouldn't notice
whoa you must be a really bad tipper
the empty coffee cup wasn't the only off
thing about that scene
we see jessie get literally thrown out
of her car along with her luggage but we
never
actually see the driver it would be
impossible for someone to have thrown
both jessie and her bags out of the car
from the driver's seat
so was there like some phantom ghost
driver that managed to reach the back
seat and then the trunk of the car
seconds apart in the episode dance dance
resolution
we see the ross family having an
everyday breakfast on their terrace with
a pitcher of orange juice in the middle
of the table
while the scene might seem ordinary if
you pay attention to that picture things
get weird
throughout the scene the orange juice
keeps randomly relocating around the
table
and almost always has a different amount
of juice in it do the rosses have a
ghost
or maybe the scene just took a lot of
takes to film and the editors were over
it
hey hey why don't you just tell her you
think you both have real
chemistry we know from experience that
miss kipling can definitely be sneaky
especially when it comes to anyone who
isn't ravi but in this episode
even we question how sneaky she could
actually be at the end of the episode
used karma
bertram scares the kids out of the
screen room so he can have it to himself
in the first shot of the scene you can
clearly see that the table next to the
chair is completely empty
but in the next shot miss kipling is
magically just chilling on it
maybe miss kipling had enough of all the
close-ups that day hey i was watching
that
bertram and the ross kids have
definitely had their fair share of
falling outs but for the most part they
always tried to help one another
and in the episode one day wonders
emma's job is trying to make bertram an
amazing dating profile to impress his
high school crush
of course that profile has to include a
perfect photo
well when emma goes to take the photo of
bertram she completely covers the camera
on the tablet
we're pretty sure not even photoshop is
going to be able to fix that photo emma
i look like america's most wanted
leprechaun emma's camera mishap wasn't
the only blip the series had with
technology
in fact there are two more times when
prop cameras just weren't cutting it
jessie's dream to become a famous
actress is a big deal in the series and
that's why in the episode caught purple
handed
getting recruited even if it's just for
her hands is a pretty big deal
we're just not sure how well those
photos will actually turn out
when the recruiter tries to take photos
of her hands with his cell phone
the audience clearly sees that the
screen of his phone actually never
leaves the home screen
i appreciate your interest but i moved
to new york to make my whole body a
store
jesse found themselves in another tizzy
in the episode the talented mr kipling
the rosses are super set on catching a
picture of the hawk that keeps circling
their building and when luke finally
does catch a photo
well take a look there is no photo
because they accidentally show us the
camera's just a prop
they should probably work on their
angles the episode 101 lizards was an
emotional one for ravi
he had to get rid of the 12 lizards that
hatched from his pal mrs kipling
well when he's saying goodbye to them he
packs them each a miniature sized
luggage but during the scene
the amount of luggage on the tray keeps
changing are we sure there were only 12
goodbye my treasures mrs kipling and i
will miss you very much
we will see you on visiting day this is
another crossover gone wrong there were
two episodes to this
jessie and good luck charlie crossover
when teddy and pj visit new york and run
into jessie and the rosses they end up
spending the holidays with them
actually i don't remember anything that
happened last night after teddy and pj
got here
yeah what you might not have noticed is
that something huge changed about their
appearance between the two episodes
both teddy and pj have completely
different color hair between parts one
and two
talk about a quick die job but really it
was only because the two episodes were
filmed so far apart in time that the
actors are the ones that mix things up
off screen okay that does explain
everything except
who the heck's charlie the scene in the
episode for broke kids is extremely hard
to miss
after losing their inheritance jessie
visits emma at her new job for a good
heart to heart
but something bizarre happens in one
shot emma is standing behind the counter
of her new job and in the next shot
she's on the other side right next to
jessie
does she have teleportation powers no
one told us about how did jesse not
notice that or more importantly
how did the editors not notice no thanks
i'm on a low plastic diet
it was brother versus brother in this
season 3 episode
white house to our house ravi and luke
have a competition to see who would be
the better mascot and are judged by the
apple salsa meter
the meter goes up when the audience
claps but when it's ravi's turn
the meter starts going up without the
audience clapping at all
even better yet he wins so did he cheat
or the cheerleaders thought your wrap
was so good they want to make you the
first ever male cheerleader in more than
history
luke spends a good portion of the
episode used karma in the rain on the
terrace
we get a shot of him kind of wet before
bertram decides to reverse his karma
and let him in but when we pan back to
luke just seconds later
he is completely drenched how did that
happen so fast
it looks like luke's actor cameron boyce
might have had to shoot the scene in the
rain
a few more times than anticipated luke
you
go upstairs and get out of these clothes
okay we're really starting to think that
the rosses have magic powers they're not
telling people about
in the episode the talented mr kipling
jesse ravi
and luke head into the lobby elevator to
get to their penthouse but when the
doors open into their home
zuri is suddenly with them how did she
magically get there
should we be calling her the great
zerdini from now on we are saying jessie
is perfectly imperfect
the editors may have let a lot of
mistakes slide but we wouldn't have the
show
any other way have you ever noticed an
error before are there any other disney
shows that have loads of mistakes like
jessie
tell us what mistake was the most
shocking for you in the comment section
below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up hit that subscribe button
ring that notification bell and we'll
see you in another video